cyberpunk 2077 was a massively hyped
game that has had a rocky
controversial launch so now we should be
even more concerned and cautious for
hogwarts legacy
wait what no that's not how it works
let me explain you're breathtaking
people of the internet retrorecontour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream
over on twitch if you want to stay up to
date on all the hogwarts legacy news
theories and speculation then be sure to
subscribe to the channel and ring the
bell so you won't miss any
new videos now just in case you haven't
heard cyberpunk 2077 has seen
quite the rocky launch the highly
anticipated title from cd projekt red
was thought
by many to be a can't miss title with
the potential to revolutionize the rpg
genre and while it seems to be a solid
game
when you can actually play it without
glitches that is it doesn't seem like
it's the revolutionary game that many
were hoping for
for some reason i keep seeing this game
popping up in the comments on my
hogwarts legacy videos people are saying
things like
i'm lowering my expectations for
hogwarts legacy now or
hopefully fans and devs learn their
lesson from cyberpunk my question is
why i don't see how cyberpunk's hype and
subsequent rocky launch has anything at
all to do with hogwarts legacy
we've seen plenty of hyped games flop
and we've also seen plenty of hyped
games do really well
now i fully understand everyone gets
hyped and excited for games in different
ways some folks prefer to set their
expectations low and hope to be
pleasantly surprised if those
expectations are
exceeded others hope for the moon so
they can really enjoy the anticipation
and the build up even if the game
doesn't ultimately meet their
expectations
i certainly think both approaches are
valid and it's totally up to you how you
choose to look forward to a game
in fact let me know down in the comments
which approach do you prefer
are you one of those people who loves
the hype and build up so you set your
hopes sky high
or are you one of the people who prefers
to set more modest expectations to try
and avoid disappointment when it comes
to cyberpunk though there's really no
reason that game alone should change how
you view hogwarts legacy
for starters it's a completely different
type of game from a completely different
developer with completely different
histories look i know here guys we are
super excited for hogwarts legacy
trust me when i say that hype and
expectations for cyberpunk were much
higher
just take a look at the twitter
following for the official cyberpunk
account
1.6 million twitter followers
versus 78 000 for hogwarts legacy it's
already been talked about on multiple
sites how the work environment of cd
projekt red was one that involved lots
of crunch multiple release date delays
you mix that with questionable marketing
that conveniently ignored the game
running on last gen consoles and now a
launch filled with bugs and glitches
as far as we know we haven't heard
anything of the sword happening at
avalanche from what little we do know
and admittedly it is a little
it appears that wb is giving avalanche
all the time they need to create a
quality game
there goes my mic marketing and how
publishers promote a game is often
incredibly important to helping set
fan expectations right now we still
don't have much to go off of in terms of
what exactly we should be expecting for
hogwarts legacy
it also seems to me that people are
equating hype and wanting to see
more of the game as somehow being equal
to fans
rushing avalanche to finish the game
which couldn't be further from the truth
while i absolutely want to hear and see
more of the game and would love to have
it in my hands
right now by no means do i want
avalanche to rush the project they
should take all the time they need to
deliver an incredible product and
hopefully wb gives them the time to do
that
at the same time i don't think there's
anything wrong with them releasing bits
of information and little teases along
the way of course at that point we're
discussing
marketing strategies as opposed to
actual game development
which is a completely different
department and something wb has plenty
of experience in doing to promote their
games
video game marketing has certainly
evolved over the years but it usually
involves a combination of trailers
screenshots dev interviews and
commercials then you have tactics like
betas or demos which usually work better
for multiplayer titles
not saying wb necessarily should do any
of these specifically
but there are a number of different ways
to market and build hype for a game
without giving too much away
should they choose to do so with
hogwarts legacy now there's also
something to be said for the
alternative strategy of keeping a game
under wraps
announcing the game and then releasing
it in relatively short order
we've seen that a few times over the
years as well and yet we know that isn't
the case with hogwarts legacy
considering they announced it in
september with a 2021 release window
i think most of our desire to see and
know more about the game stems from the
fact that we still don't fully know
where to set our expectations
at least in my view i feel avalanche and
wb would be best served by getting in
front
of these expectations early release more
information that would help fans to
calibrate our expectations a little bit
ultimately fans and avalanche want the
same thing here
an amazingly well-crafted action rpg set
in the wizarding world that stays true
to its roots i certainly wish the best
to the devs at cd projekt red and hope
they get their
game into a state that players on all
consoles can enjoy
in no way do i think it should dampen
your hype for hogwarts legacy
our hype and expectations should be
based solely on what avalanche and wb
decide to show and tell us before the
launch of the game
and also just how you yourself prefer to
get hyped and look forward to games
that's entirely up to you as always
thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon